ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el mundo
sigue enfocado en toda su atención en el
avance de la pandemia del cob y 19 y en
buscar mecanismos para combatirla pero
paralela a esta coyuntura mundial hay
otras realidades que siguen ahí que
persisten y que no podemos dejarlas de
lado y mucho menos pues bajar los brazos
hablamos de la lucha contra el vih/sida
una epidemia así lo califica por lo
menos la organización de naciones unidas
los primeros casos fueron registrados en
eeuu hace poco más de 40 años cuando las
autoridades reportaron a hombres en las
ciudades de los ángeles nueva york y san
francisco que estaban sanos y comenzaron
a padecer formas muy raras de cáncer
también neumonía además de algunas
infecciones oportunistas por lo menos
así la califican los médicos en 1982 por
primera vez se refieren a esta rara
enfermedad como sida y un año después en
1983 determinan que el sida es causado
por el vih desde entonces los avances
han sido inmensos pero esta enfermedad
todavía no tiene cura
prevención sigue siendo la mejor arma
para combatirla pero cómo prevenir
cuando su mayor presencia está en las
zonas más pobres de nuestro planeta y en
donde hay muy pocos recursos les voy a
dar algunas cifras para ponerlos en
contexto de la magnitud de la epidemia
del vih/sida en el mundo tenemos
alrededor de
37,7 millones de personas que vivían con
vih en el 2020 6 como a un millón de
personas se vivían sin saber que tenían
vih también en el año 2020 la áfrica
subsahariana concentra cerca del 67 por
ciento de las personas que viven con el
vih en nuestro planeta del total de
quienes viven con vih el 53 por ciento
son mujeres y niñas
la lucha contra el vih a nivel mundial
tuvo un revés con la llegada de la
pandemia del cob y 19 muchos de los
recursos destinados para el estudio del
vih y el desarrollo de una posible
vacuna fueron redireccionados a la lucha
contra el hobby 19 aún sabiendo que las
personas que tienen vih están en
desventaja en términos de salud ante el
coronavirus y por qué porque las
personas con vih sufren cuadros mucho
más graves de kobe 19 así lo demuestra
la experiencia y los estudios que han
hecho a lo largo de los últimos meses
también presentan mayores comorbilidades
a mediados del 2021 la mayoría de las
personas que vivían con vih no tenían
acceso a las vacunas contra el jove y 19
pero algo bueno nos deja la pandemia del
cobi 19 para la lucha contra el vih
desde el desarrollo de una vacuna la
vacuna del aire n mensajero esta
tecnología puede abrir la puerta a una
vacuna efectiva contra el vih o nuevos
escenarios por lo menos para un
tratamiento o para prevenir esta
enfermedad la enfermedad del sida que la
desarrolla a partir del vih todo está
por hacer a finales del 2020 habían unos
21.500 millones de dólares disponibles
para dar una respuesta al sida la
enfermedad que genera el vih ya lo decía
en los países por lo menos en los de
bajos ingresos y también de ingresos
medios pero onusida estima que para el
2025 es decir ya a la vuelta de la
esquina serán necesarios 29 mil millones
de dólares para esta misma respuesta
para los países de ingresos altos medios
y bajos es decir para el planeta entero
de dónde van a salir estos dineros
cuando hay una otra epidemia en marcha y
también cuando están escaseando los
recursos
precisamente el 1º de diciembre es la
fecha mundial para conmemorar el día
internacional de la lucha contra el
vih/sida una fecha que sirve para hacer
balance de la situación de la lucha a lo
largo de estos años los logros y también
las labores pendientes les damos más
detalles en el siguiente informe
elaborado por la redacción de france 24
jean-louis oye cope ma es un paciente
con vih de república democrática del
congo tiene 60 años y gracias a los
medicamentos ha podido mantener buena
calidad de vida sin embargo su situación
cambió con la última de las pandemias de
conavi risk el coronavirus y el ébola
eclipsaron al vih esto no es posible os
pido que los fondos para el vih sean
consistentes de lo contrario la gente
morirá william moore por primera vez en
20 años los diagnósticos y pruebas de
vih se detuvieron en 2020 y la mayoría
de personas con el virus no tienen
acceso a una vacuna de kobe 19 la
pandemia agravó problemas estructurales
en senegal y acceso a la paz las
desigualdades son la base de muchos
males especialmente en la lucha contra
el sida
si no se respetan los derechos humanos
si hay estigma y discriminación si se
deja a la gente atrás
aumentan los riesgos del vih
en el mundo hay actualmente 37 7
millones de casos registrados el 73%
tiene acceso a una terapia pero sigue
siendo mortal en 2020 fallecieron 680
mil portadores del virus mientras los
datos de onusida cuestionan el
compromiso de acabar con el virus para
2030 tenemos de red 20 youtube hay
fronteras las noticias que traigo hoy en
este informe son la cruda advertencia de
que el sida sigue siendo una pandemia
cada minuto que pasa estamos perdiendo
una preciosa vida a causa del sida y no
tenemos ese tiempo hab time
la innovación con vacunas a rm para
luchar contra el hobbit 19 ha abierto la
posibilidad de encontrar una solución
para el vih la farmacéutica moderna está
trabajando en ello una esperanza que las
organizaciones piden que vaya acompañada
de prevención clave para combatir esta y
otras pandemias
bueno pues a grandes rasgos así es como
están las cosas la lucha contra el
vih/sida en el marco de la pandemia del
cobi 19 es nuestro tema de debate aquí
en france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado al doctor daniel scott el
inmunólogo virólogo director de
investigaciones del instituto pasteur en
parís él es franco venezolano y nos
atiende desde parís la capital francesa
también se conecta a esta conversación
jaime valencia él es director de la ong
aid for aids colombia nos atiende desde
la ciudad de cali en el sur occidente de
colombia y en el estudio de france 24
nos acompaña el doctor eric delgado el
es magister en enfermedades infecciosas
y vih también es especialista en
epidemiología y salud pública ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate
comentarios y preguntas lo pueden hacer
a través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram en
twitter estamos como france24 guión bajo
es santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas para que participen en
este debate de france 24 comienzo con el
doctor scott en la ciudad de parís en la
capital francesa preguntándole en sobre
un balance por estos 40 años después de
los hallazgos de los primeros casos de
vih en el mundo que fueron como ya lo
decíamos detectados en eeuu y dejando un
poco de lado el contexto de la pandemia
de kobe 19 para analizarlo más adelante
pero cuál es el balance que usted hace
de el avance que hemos tenido en la
tecnología en el desarrollo de una
posible vacuna de tratamientos de sobre
todo mejorar la calidad de vida a las
personas que padecen esta enfermedad
sí buenas tardes este realmente quería
decir primero que todo que precisamente
la investigación en el sida y en el vih
ha llevado a que actualmente por ejemplo
tengamos una vacuna contra el coming en
un año dos años y que sea efectiva todo
lo que se ha desarrollado en paralelo
para
mejorar la vida y la calidad de la vida
de los pacientes ha ayudado no solamente
al paciente con vih sino también a los
otros pacientes que se beneficien de
esto de estos avances y realmente yo
creo que es bueno los mayores avances
han sido desde el punto de vista
terapéutico y desde el punto de vista
prevención últimamente con lo que
llamamos la prepa ya que es la
prevención ante el 'pole position' yo
creo que todos estos protocolos de
estudios que se han llevado a cabo
ha contribuido a que los pacientes
primero que todo tenga una mejor calidad
de vida
teniendo la fecha
importante de esos avances doctor scott
en la ciudad de parís pasó a preguntarle
a jaime valència en la ciudad de cali
desde su perspectiva cuáles son los
avances destacados a lo largo de estos
40 años que falta por hacer qué balance
hace usted
bueno yo coincido con el doctor y creo
que el mayor avance es un tratamiento y
definitivamente tratamiento ahora es
para versión ahora la dejamos con las
herramientas que gracias a la ciencia
tenemos podemos decir que podemos parar
la epidemia del sida por eso estamos con
la estrategia 95 95 95 para para el 2030
cuando una persona en tratamiento cuando
se diagnostica a tiempo y se empieza no
también todo el tiempo pues expectativa
de vida es igual que cualquier persona
que no tenga vih y encima costo una
carga vial detectable para que el vídeo
no circule no se detecta a nivel
sanguíneo pues no transmite
el vih
entonces creo que las herramientas las
tenemos a pesar de que no tenemos una
vacuna vida pura pero las herramientas
las tenemos para terminar por la
pandemia
desafortunadamente pues todavía sigue
porque es un diagnóstico no más social
todavía sigue las inequidades y la falta
de discriminación el estigma que que no
permiten que el vih en verdad que esta
estrategia se cumpla
mantengamos todavía estás cifras que
muestras que son muy desafortunadas a
pesar de 40 años de historia con el vih
entre nosotros la iniquidad y el estigma
dos temas que vamos a tratar más
adelante que en el programa jaime
importante que los haya mencionado aquí
en su balance y en su introducción y
aquí en el estudio france24 me acompaña
el doctor eric delgado y le hago la
misma pregunta para comenzar esta
discusión doctor delgado su perspectiva
su opinión del balance que usted hace
estos 40 años de lucha contra el sida
bueno pienso que para complementar lo
que lo que han dicho mis colegas
efectivamente la connotación del ingreso
de la terapia antiretroviral como la
conocemos
aproximadamente sobre 1996 tuvo un
cambio notable en la morbilidad y en la
mortalidad de los pacientes con vih
posteriormente estas terapias han ido
simplificando se buscando que los
pacientes tengan mayor adherencia a los
programas entonces este punto de partida
de adherencia
ha favorecido y ha impactado
notablemente en los programas y
posteriormente en los diez años cinco
años ese ha venido fortaleciendo la el
establecer terapias pre exposición que
en ese momento para el mundo y para
américa latina cuenta con más de 300 mil
pacientes los cuales han estado en
seguimiento continuo y en estudio para
prevenir de cierta manera la transmisión
y lograr esta meta al 2030 que es
detener la epidemia del virus del vih 40
años de lucha el doctor delgado
contra esta enfermedad contra el
vih/sida eeuu en algún momento digamos
se puso la camiseta para combatir esta
enfermedad y dijo que en 10 años iba a
tener una vacuna cuáles son las
dificultades con las que se han
encontrado la comunidad científica los
médicos para poder lograr tener esa
esperada vacuna que la espera la
comunidad mundial entera y más en el
contexto en el que estamos bueno pienso
que ahí hay dos o tres puntos sobre los
cuales se ha dificultado el llegar a la
vacuna es de una manera rápida y
oportuna el primero y específicamente
los recursos se requieren muchos más
recursos mucha más investigación
el segundo punto son las características
del virus digamos que el virus tiene una
connotación que conocemos como
reservorios que genera ciertos
santuarios dentro del cuerpo del ser
humano
y el tercer punto que es un poco más
difícil porque si se ha adelantado y no
hemos logrado efectiva de superiores al
50% en la vacuna principalmente ha dado
por las características del virus por
las características de replicación de
mutación sí y de generación de una
respuesta inmune fortalecida y sólida
frente al virus sin embargo pensamos en
la comunidad científica que en los
siguientes 10 años así como hemos
logrado terapia simplificación de
terapias es donde potencialmente en unos
años vamos a tener tratamientos de seis
meses de un año y una inyección una
tableta potencialmente vamos a tener la
vacuna en los siguientes diez años si se
enfatizan en sus esfuerzos
principalmente en investigación en
nanotecnología sí que es una de las
esperanzas en en la vacunación doctor
scott en la ciudad de parís le hago la
misma pregunta para que usted desee
sobre el avance en la vacuna usted lo
mencionaba que hoy tenemos una vacuna
que nos sirve para protegernos del cob y
19 gracias a los avances que ha habido
en el set desarrollo en esa búsqueda de
una vacuna contra el vih/sida que falta
el doctor delgado dice que en unos 10
años puede haber unos grandes avances
cuál es su perspectiva y yo creo que es
que sí que se ha avanzado mucho en el
aspecto vamos a decir virológico
inmunológico para combatir el virus del
sida y como indicó el colega
anteriormente hay problemas que son muy
diferentes muy particulares al al virus
del sida por ejemplo con respecto al
kobe 19 entonces les recuerdo que cuando
se habla de reservorio es porque el
virus entra en el adn de la célula se
integra en el adn de la célula cuando la
mayoría de los giro lo que hacen es
replicar en el citoplasma y no entran en
el programa genético de la célula
yo creo que una de las partes que
llevaba mucha investigación últimamente
es precisamente buscar dar nuevas
terapias para atacar el virus en el adn
ya lo que tenemos ahorita son terapias
para atacar el virus cuando él replica
pero no lo podemos atacar cuando está
latente la dulce eso debe ser una
investigación que se debe llevar a cabo
en
los próximos años lo otro con respecto a
la vacuna es que hay mucha como dijo el
doctor muchas cepas vitalex por
mutaciones o por intercambio entre cepas
y eso hace un poco difícil porque el
virus escapa la respuesta inmunitaria
después hay varios tipos de genes de
individuos que sabemos que controlan la
enfermedad pero cada individuo tiene
cada grupo de individuo tiene una
particularidad hay factores genéticos
hay factores de respuesta inmunológica
y eso lo que se trata de buscar con la
vacuna pero con estos dos factores los
individuos son diferentes y el virus
también es diferente con el tiempo
entonces hace mucho difícil muy difícil
encontrar una vacuna y ya le doy la
palabra a jaime en la ciudad de cali
quiero hacerle una pregunta corta al
doctor scott y es haciendo la
investigación para este programa y
encontré algo que yo no tenía ni la más
mínima idea que hay vih-1 vih-2 no sabía
que había como dos variantes distintas
no sé cuál será el término médico para
llamarlo en qué se diferencia que la
distancia y si las dos están presentes
en todo el mundo o alguna está en un
sector específico del planeta o en qué
lugar se encuentra si son dos ramas etc
para mayores cepa diferente el uno y el
dos el uno el que está más expandido por
todo por todo el mundo
el 2 está más restringido a áfrica y
para
dar más o menos una idea desde el punto
de vista genético el vih-1 está más
cerca del virus sin ya no de ninguna
deficiencia mientras que el 2010 veía
que no está mucho más lejos sería eso
constituye también una parte una
investigación porque el vamos a ser el
vih-1 lleva un deterioro sin
intervención terapéutica lleva a un
deterioro progresivo del sistema
inmunitario cambio el vih-2 no en el vih
2 tiene etapas mucho más lenta y
entonces probablemente porque el sistema
inmunitario puede mejor control de este
virus que están más lejos genéticamente
de los otros o
importante hacer esa aclaración y paso
preguntarle a jaime en valencia en la
ciudad de cali usted trabaja en una ong
está en contacto con diferentes sectores
sociales allí en la ciudad de cali en el
sur occidente de colombia pero desde su
perspectiva que está comprometida está
la sociedad de cali o colombiana o
latinoamericana como usted lo quiera
enfocar en la lucha contra el vih/sida
de pronto porque llevamos ya 40 años
hablando de este tema se volvió parte
del paisaje y el ciudadano común perdió
el interés por lo que suceda por la
lucha por colaborar por estar al tanto
de los avances por estar al tanto del
cuidado para las personas que
perspectiva tiene usted
desafortunadamente el vih como hablo con
con mi director ejecutivo pasó de moda y
la gente ya ya no quiere hablar de vih
sobre y también que todavía existen
muchos mitos y muchos tabús dentro de la
sociedad y es algo que nos llama mucho
la atención porque nosotros continuamos
diciendo lo mismo desde hace 20 años 25
años que que yo empecé digo el mismo
discurso cuando oí las conferencias a mí
me sorprende porque no solamente la
falta digamos de conocimiento y de
información referente al vih incluso en
la población en general y muchas veces
incluso en el sector médico
en la parte educativa por ejemplo a
nivel de colegios a los directores los
profesores que están encargados de
llevar la información tampoco tienen la
información correcta a pesar de de
tantos de tantos años y el problema
básicamente es es por los tabús los
mitos que el diagnóstico como tal trae
donde la gente no quiere darse cuenta no
quiere saber sobre el vih le da miedo le
da miedo saber el estigma la
discriminación hacia las comunidades que
están en riesgo vulnerables al vih a la
homofobia y la transfobia
y ahora en colombia y en la región con
los migrantes y refugiados venezolanos a
que también están en gran riesgo a hacer
hacia la infección y también que son
objeto de grandes estigma y
discriminación
ya le doy la palabra doctor delgado
quiero hacer otra pregunta a jaime en la
ciudad de cali precisamente sobre el
estigma y es difícil romper ese estigma
es difícil romper ese mito porque
latinoamérica en sí es una sociedad de
una región muy conservadora en donde
todavía hay muchos prejuicios para
hablar de estos temas que conciernen
sexualidad homosexualidad y también
drogas
en el mundo entero se habla con más
libertad como lo ve usted
si es bastante difícil estar aparte
también religiosa y
somos una población muy con ser muy
conserva y muy conservadora en muchos
años y no es fácil en los colegios
llevar educación sexual
no es fácil es muy difícil a los padres
se oponen mucho a llevar la educación a
sus hijos entonces si no empezamos a
educación sexual desde jovencitos pues
que son que esperamos que después de las
generaciones también va a ser nuevas no
va a ser fácil y mientras exista esto
mientras existen dificultades
en la sociedad
y esto si estas creencias arraigadas
dentro de la sociedad que se van es de
generación en generación y no va a ser
fácil producir los cambios claro hay que
hablar todavía todavía hay una lucha ahí
para hablar libremente sobre este tema
quiero que vengamos al contexto actual
en el que estamos y la pandemia del cobi
19 doctor delgado como afectado el
contexto en el que estamos la pandemia
del cob y alrededor del mundo a la lucha
contra el vih/sida en la investigación
en los tratamientos en el desarrollo
incluso en los presupuestos para el
desarrollo y la lucha bueno pues lo que
hemos visto es que él pues nadie estaba
preparado para que llegara una pandemia
y de un mes a otro se presentaron una
serie de factores que llevaron a que se
cerrara absolutamente todo y esto
impactó directamente en los programas de
vih en la detección de los de los
pacientes con vih en esa búsqueda activa
que teníamos inicial de identificar de
manera temprana la población con este
diagnóstico
vemos como recientemente en una encuesta
que hizo conocida encontraron como 5 de
cada 10 pacientes tuvo algún
inconveniente en la entrega del
medicamento antirretroviral solamente 3
de cada 10 pacientes tuvieron acceso a
telemedicina dos de cada diez pacientes
se les pudo entregar medicamentos en su
casa cierto teniendo en cuenta todo este
contexto de cierre de aeropuertos de
transporte entonces muchos
y llegaron a perder tratamientos por 1 2
3 meses y mucho más esto eso jugó un
papel negativo en la estrategia y en en
ese primer y en el segundo y tercer 90
del que estábamos buscando como lo dice
mi colega en el cual buscamos no
solamente que tengan adherencia a la
terapia antiretroviral que tengan
supresión biológica frente al
tratamiento entonces con este
con esta no entrega oportuna el
tratamiento con esa no valoración pues
obviamente se aumentó la morbilidad en
los pacientes no relacionados con kobe
pero sí relacionados con su patología y
obviamente esto tenía un impacto
negativo en los pacientes ahora el otro
punto es el los recursos económicos
porque vemos como los diferentes
gobiernos pues incrementaron sus
recursos se hicieron una serie de leyes
decretos buscando obviamente minimizar
el impacto de lakovic y esto impactó
negativamente probablemente en esos
compromisos que teníamos de búsqueda y
de
y llegar a más del 90% a la población
con terapia antirretroviral doctor scott
en la ciudad de parís de acuerdo a este
escenario que nos explica el doctor
delgado de cómo se han desviado los
recursos los pacientes no pudieron
acceder a sus medicamentos a sus
tratamientos falta también algunas
personas que a lo mejor no han sido
diagnosticadas a tiempo
por este desvío de recursos y por por el
confinamiento y la pandemia estamos a
nivel de la sociedad mundial
preparándonos para lo que viene como
consecuencia de esto en un par de años
es decir personas
el incremento de personas fallecidas por
enfermedades relacionadas con el
vih/sida más personas contagiadas
precisamente por no cuidarse a tiempo y
también por no acceder a los
medicamentos pertinentes estamos
preparados para ese escenario
yo creo que yo creo que no
lamentablemente o sea que como ustedes
dijeron en la introducción el problema
es que las personas que están más
infectadas en proporción con el virus
del sida se encuentran en áfrica y en
asia que son dos regiones que tienen y
también como lo dijeron poco acceso a
vamos a decir al servicio médico
habitual no voy a decir el estándar
europeo o el estándar del américa del
norte pero ni siquiera un estándar a
nivel estándar normal para el servicio
médico entonces eso ha llevado a que no
tienen como digamos tenía acceso a la
vacuna vemos como en áfrica estamos
viendo que hay menos del 20 por ciento
de la población que está vacuna contra
el kobe y
y tenemos entonces nuevas mutaciones en
el virus y en el áfrica del sur en el
país que quieren más contaminación en el
mundo de vih precisamente entonces todo
eso va a afectar en todo un sistema
hospitalario que es
también estableció como lo podemos
pensar nosotros ya que nos toca
prepararnos para ese escenario que puede
ser en unos cuantos meses o años este
escenario
después de estos meses de descuido de
estos tratamientos por consecuencia de
la pandemia de kobe 19 me quedan pocos
minutos quiero hablar con jaime sobre la
disparidad en los accesos a los
tratamientos en los accesos a los
mecanismos de control y también de
prevención sigue siendo américa latina
una región muy relegada en cuanto al
acceso a otorgar esos tratamientos a las
personas que son diagnosticadas con el
vih/sida
bueno he avanzado en américa latina ha
avanzado de cuánto cobertura universal a
tratamientos
que de pronto en algunos países los
avances son los últimos medicamentos que
puedan estar saliendo en los países
desarrollados no llegan a su debido
tiempo
no a nuestros países de todas maneras
todavía existen en muchas ocasiones
muchos vacíos en el en el acceso a
tratamiento por la falta a veces de los
gobiernos de todo lo que son mecanismos
de compras
y eso hace que en algunas ocasiones las
personas pues se queden sin el acceso a
la medicina que necesita constantemente
también hay ciertos países que
donde por ejemplo en colombia el sistema
de salud algunas veces no permite si las
personas por ejemplo no están en el
trabajando o se queda sin trabajo muchas
veces como no ha tocado nosotros
el sistema digamos los seguros no lo
cubren y se quedan con vacíos
bueno pues ya me quedan en la recta
final de este programa yo no puedo dejar
de hablar doctor delgado doctor scott y
jaime valencia en cali del caso africano
es lamentable este continente sigue
siendo una deuda pendiente del planeta
entero en cuanto a la ayuda que se le
puede dar para que este continente luche
contra el vih/sida porque también están
luchando contra una epidemia de ébola
luchan contra el joven 19 contra
enfermedades producidas allí como por
ejemplo la malaria bueno otro tipo de
enfermedades que podrían mencionar allí
porque áfrica tan rezagado porque áfrica
tan atrás porque al mundo le cuesta
tanto hacer un poco de balance y
ayudarle a esta región que la que más
está padeciendo esta enfermedad
mira que es algo paradójico porque hay
muchos estudios en el momento donde
nosotros podemos tomar decisiones
clínicas
con base en estudios que se hacen en
áfrica o sea muchos de los estudios en
vih que el mundo conoce en este momento
en el cual se hacen intervenciones para
salvar vídeos en pacientes con vih se
hacen en áfrica
pienso que hay varias varias cosas
primero el punto de vista o el del
contexto del
país como tal y del continente si de
pronto la falta de unión la falta de
interés a cierto y el segundo es que los
países más desarrollados pues no no
miran allá no miran a áfrica como un
continente que potencialmente puede
aportar muchísimo más al mundo si la
otra cosa es que los pacientes con vih
en el áfrica desafortunadamente en a
diferencia de otros países de américa
latina o de europa
digamos cuentan con sistemas de salud
robustos o con sistemas de salud no tan
robustos pero sí si hay una intervención
salud hay un sistema entonces
en las minorías los grupos las
distancias dentro de todo el continente
son limitantes que impactan
negativamente en ese 67% de pacientes
que están con vih pero pienso que si se
encaminarán recursos políticas aunque
onusida lo hace porque uno es testigo de
que de una u otra manera ellos han
intervenido para actuar sobre la
población del continente africano
estamos cortos estamos cortos en este
continente para lograr la estrategia de
90 90 90 de ellos y falta mucho falta
mucho y vemos cómo kobe
desafortunadamente nos muestra
la cruda realidad del continente y en
cierta forma se dio un poco reversa en
algunos avances que había en el
continente africano en cuanto a la lucha
contra el vih/sida doctor scott sus
impresiones sobre el caso africano ya
para el cierre del programa
bueno es un sistema sumamente complejo o
sea desde el punto de vista social desde
el punto de vista económico
que el problema es que en áfrica no hay
fronteras realmente porque todo el mundo
viaja entre los diferentes países y eso
fue lo que ayudó mucho inicialmente a la
transmisión de la epidemia y es
sumamente complejo el caso de áfrica
como dijo el doctor por ejemplo los
estudios de la transmisión materno fetal
para impedir la transmisión del virus
comenzaron en áfrica que los estudios
primeros que salieron ahí fueron en
áfrica y que dieron la pauta
también quiero quiero hacer un
comentario porque hablamos mucho de
la parte tecnológica de los avances de
la agencia adelante porque me queda ya
un minuto para asignar el programa lo
que lo que quiero decir es que nosotros
no podemos hacer nada si no tenemos la
asociación de pacientes con nosotros
y precisamente la defensa de los
pacientes con sida fue lo que trajo
ahora diferentes asociaciones de
pacientes en toda una serie de
enfermedades claro bueno pues ya me
quedan pocos segundos para terminar el
programa jaime valencia en la ciudad de
cali y su conclusión de lo que falta
entonces en esta lucha para ponerle otra
vez aceleradores y ver otra vez
resultados rápidamente
bueno yo creo que es importante lo que
está lo que está diciendo conducir a las
inequidades mientras no combatir
combatamos las inequidades y sobre todo
en los países de bajos y medianos
ingresos va a ser muy difícil terminar
con lo con la pandemia por eso se
proyecta si no pasa si no pasa algo
ahora en vez de terminar por la pandemia
para el 2030 vamos a tener más de 7 casi
8 millones de muertes
solamente relacionados al vih doctor
delgado que en el estudio su conclusión
20 segundos
principalmente en los países los
diferentes países de américa latina han
venido haciendo la actualización en sus
guías de manejo de vih esta
actualización ha buscado simplificar los
tratamientos antiretrovirales
pienso que hacen falta intervenciones
más fuertes en salud pública
específicamente en la búsqueda de los
casos
un ejemplo uno de cada dos pacientes se
está encontrando en estado sida entonces
la búsqueda de sus pacientes de una
manera temprana la intervención y la
prevención deben ser los pilares
fundamentales del manejo de vih se me
acaba el tiempo doctor scott gracias por
habernos acompañado desde la ciudad de
parís jaime en valencia en la ciudad de
cali el doctor erick delgado aquí en el
estudio france24 gracias por haber
compartido con nosotros estas
impresiones sobre esta lucha contra la
vida de sida ustedes sigan dejando todos
sus comentarios y preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]